de la mairie de paris à la course à
l'elysée
anne hidalgo se lance à son tour à
l'assaut de la présidentielle
ultime étape pour la socialiste
longtemps resté dans l'ombre de l'ancien
maire de paris bertrand delanoë
on voulait aussi caricaturé en groupie
du maire ah ouais ouais
mars 2001 début de son parcours
politique
à l'époque celle qui n'est encore qu'une
inconnue se présente aux municipales
dans le 15e arrondissement de paris à 41
ans est féministe déclaré mère de deux
enfants fait l'unanimité à gauche on la
décrit comme une femme de séduction de
talent et de conviction et certains lui
promettent déjà un avenir ministériel
anne hidalgo pairs au second tour mais
devient conseillère de paris pendant sa
campagne elle se fait remarquer par
bertrand delanoë tout juste élu maire de
la capitale il la nomme première
adjointe renza est chargée de l'égalité
femmes hommes bertrand delanoë a tenu à
ce que je sois à ses côtés c'est une de
de confiance un grand honneur et c'est
un énorme travail qui nous attendent
anne hidalgo reste dans l'ombre de
bertrand delanoë jusqu'en octobre 2002
lors de la nuit blanche
le maire de paris est victime d'une
agression au couteau pendant plusieurs
semaines la socialiste sort de
l'anonymat il remplace son mentor
capitaine non non non ça je ne me
permettrais pas et
si vous parlez de l'hôtel de ville voilà
on assure la continuité à côté de sa
fonction d'adjointe anne hidalgo se
présente à plusieurs élections
législatives en 2002 et 2007 où elle
s'incline en 2008 elle se lance encore
une fois aux municipales toujours dans
le xvème à paris bertrand delanoë ne
tarissait pas d'éloges sur sa protégée
[Applaudissements]
elle a du caractère bourru dirait la
d'autorité mais elle est toujours d'une
douceur et donc je sais qu'elle est
meilleure que moi
anne hidalgo échoue encore mais elle est
maintenue comme première adjointe quatre
ans plus tard en 2012 bertrand delanoë
décide de ne pas se représenter à la
mairie de paris anne hidalgo se lance
dans la course à l'hôtel de ville et à
droite la candidate fait peur
il assure elle a beaucoup davantage elle
a beaucoup travaillé avec le maire de
paris elle a suivi soutenu et y assure
c'est une très bonne candidate et
le 5 avril 2014 après 18 mois d'une
longue campagne anne hidalgo est élu
maire de paris elle devient la première
femme à occuper ce poste avant d'être
élu une seconde fois en 2000 ans
[Musique]